hi guys I'm Greg hi guys I'm Brianna
Brianna white is back from the strange
rebel gaming channel I did get her I
retired out of myself at first
hey guys that's a drumroll you hear that
we really want the patreon so we got a
patron of the day shoutout for you guys
let's do it lucky person today the
newest member of the patron community
the latest person to be part of the
patreon community and your Hays thank
you for making a contribution to support
the channel my friend you freaking rock
will give you an extended shadow at the
end of this video
yeah but before we do that we're gonna
watch John boyega prank Star Wars fans
with surprise photo bomb at celebration
so excited for this because I saw was it
last year's force for change video with
hair yeah before popping up on you guys
this awesome so this I'm great this is
probably going to be cool it is actually
photobombing
so can you strike your best tonight and
put it for me that's great perfect
that's one big plan oh my god great hey
guys it's gem wearing a hair and if you
have it enter for your chance to win the
grand prize in the latest Star Wars
force of change campaign what are you
waiting for we've got not one not two
but three ones a lifetime Star Wars
experiences waiting for one lucky has to
appear at week and also be in the
running for an additional chance to join
the cast at the red carpet premiere of
Star Wars the last Jedi to show you what
I like I'm here at Star Wars Celebration
to surprise a few friends of a red
carpet experience they'll never forget
I'll also be joining the fun but yeah
[Music]
right boys come stand over here Andrea
cool you look great look good it looks
amazing
and this is a recipe real beauty that
they use in our there buddy
Wow Wow it will not be PA who's your
favorite character right yeah she's so
great I love her baby really and not
only for my lifetime of the questions
though I like the POE and Finn dynamic
so that was like my toes does the to the
pair NAS Oceana to very character if you
end up dominating to the campaign you
could end up at the premiere of the last
Jedi so very cool yeah what if you met
John boyega emplacement Ivan Haley shot
right Jim oh [ __ ]
just imagine you're a so premier and you
see John boyega that's a special thing
because being one of the first black
characters you know I've been looking
for balls off the entire committee alien
do you want to see some photos
sure good look right here for this first
one handle your kylo Ren energy tellers
dismount no smile on kylo Ren doesn't
smile okay let's photo bomb bb-8 like
you're like how's that well you can
hyper really so one that really came out
awesome USB sure hey you like that a
factory
wait a minute oh my gosh I lucky bastard
[Music]
city the Hat on him
thank you your best red carpet spoon for
me the best bench especially carpets in
my lucky bastard oh man seriously house
radio system we only perform we will
conduct a man 80s bidet thank you being
a force of change are you ready to
strike that red carpet code then click
the link okay - Oh mein Kampf slash Star
Wars good job last year every entry puts
you in the running for the grand prize I
love it sanics chance to join the cast
at the world premiere Star Wars the last
Jedi so let's do even more to support be
incredibly welcome runners there are two
Starlight Children's Foundation oh yeah
may the force be with you likewise
[Music]
John boyega when I first saw this guy
was a literally collie okay yes means
you're calling in a ball machine right
excited I just got puppy oh damn I'm not
like like a coke addict now that's okay
the coke addict looks good on you maybe
you can play a coke addict in the next
criminal mind it's only everybody has
dreams yeah what play coke addict I
loved it I would go to Gary restricted
mode on YouTube uh John boyega first
movie I saw man was attacked the block
he was so good in that but I thought he
was that kind of guy yeah I thought he
was this tough serious like you don't
[ __ ] with this dude kind of attitude but
ever since you played Finn and seeing
him an interview isn't seeing this
you're like scheduling goofy
[ __ ] a guy yeah super goofy guy
super friendly I love it I love it
personality is just someone you want to
be friends with I love them so much I
hope one day we can build up our fame
enough to the point where we can do a
surprise thing like that while people
are like making love and we just come in
not like actually you know people want
to be a force for change and some people
want to surprise people adding tags I
mean there's all kinds of people yeah I
would like keep their doors I'd knock it
on so great all right I'm out of here
I'll be the most I got here boys we're
good yeah of course we're good yeah
course for change in jeez what if this
happened to you
what if you were doing a photo and then
John boyega showed up I'm when I did
surprised I cried so I would immediately
start streaming what you really my gosh
no question I wouldn't cry yeah I would
be all like Kristen Bell meeting a swab
okay yeah I was sorry
yeah what what Star Wars character would
get you to that point
Oh a lot of them would obviously the
strong women so like Daisy Ridley is an
easy one because any strong woman I'm
like you've done a lot for young women
yeah if you would ask me this a year ago
I would have said Carrie Fisher but
unfortunately I'm never gonna get that
chance which is that I'm sorry this
video is a sad turn yeah you asked me
exactly the question sorry no but like I
would do that I like the bar isn't that
very high for me to start insta crying
so like pretty much anybody that I would
yeah yeah like you know the guy who's
like in the trap I'm with you on that
evening I'm sorry even if I had a
business meeting with Daisy Ridley I
would probably cry in the business
meeting upon meeting her she and her man
yeah yeah what I need to be a surprise
it would just need to be like an
official yeah I have ready go stick your
glass it would happen right away yeah
when people don't have that sense about
them I'm a lost into someone else who
has that sense the world revolves around
these people in a good way and I think
there's much good beautiful genuine off
of people so I think one of the things I
love most about the force for change
started Harrison Ford and it continues
to John boyega I just love to see major
major celebrities who don't have to do
this but who choose to be a part of
philanthropic ventures are you sure
they're not being forced to they might
be for the in their contract yeah I do
not know people can't really force
Harrison Ford to do anything ya know
that's kind of true I'm sure you didn't
under the goodness of his heart you
don't really know why some celebrities
don't do more things like this but it
really just does make a difference when
you see people like this like John
boyega who I'm sure is nervous being
around normal people because yeah people
probably go a little bit crazy around
him he did it anyway
you know he completely selfless even him
one of the stars of the latest Star Wars
Mia
he even seemed surprised and people
showed all dressed up like I had their
outfits you he was even like 100
some people do this no matter the first
time you ever noticed that
you just seem so humble and I just love
to see celebrities there's something
special about being a celebrity be
humble a gentleman
oh yeah that's not gonna be me probably
not no no no I have a goodly frumble
person I'm far from humble
oh man the ego on this guy is through
the roof it's hard to fit my answer
yours in this room right now because I'm
suffocating that's why you're sneezing
nothing is allergic to my okay yeah I
could just really imagine being in
someone's position as a fan and having
this happen to them must be like one of
the most magical moments in our life and
to have it broadcasted all over YouTube
whatever you something is special I do
wonder like how many all the people that
are seeing this video like does that
girl's mom like what yeah I'm always
that always makes me curious to think
about to and you see things like this
and this is only four and a half minutes
and knowing my way yeah I'm sure there's
a lot more fans I got to have this
experience yeah I just love out the the
one black guy was was a quickie sockets
no no yes you like you like that effect
we didn't like was awesome yeah very
meta to do videos like this because
we're honestly reacting to people's
reaction like react second oh my god my
blowing alright guys oh hey Brianna why
thank you for being here
yo myself you can go check out Brianna
wise gaming channel strange rebel gaming
what game is going up next or as they
are playing horizon zero dawn Mass
Effect Andromeda grows the wild and
Final Fantasy 15 we're conditioning Wow
there you go there you go go great game
go check out our channel following her
on social media all in the description
box you can subscribe to the real reject
this thing called the notification bell
that's apparently important you should
click that yeah cuz subscriptions mean
nothing conscription means nothing
anymore to do this is how you get good
at being honest talk about YouTube in
its laws
telling your viewers how they can get to
my videos is that not advertised
advertiser friendly and hey hey hey you
know what I'm saying hey with an HJ why
because we're talking about anime the
patron of the day Andrew it means the
world to us that you help contribute to
the real Rejects community you're a
superstar you my friend you should put
an end in between the Y&S of your name
game hannes because i wouldn't you like
a photo of you and some haines underwear
i think he's willing to do it I'm
surprised your fruit is a little kind of
guy I try their underwear it is not
especially comfortable my mom bought me
a pair from Target it really itched
their advertiser lied to me yeah yeah
that's how you know he's not advertising
in the loom yeah don't do that
Andrew Hayes everywhere you go I want
you to know that I'm saying hey to you
my friend and that's a stupid joke I
love you